foreign
[Music]
most of us living here in the host
nations are caught up in the World Cup
frenzy I'm headed to Central Doha where
there's someone who's not just serving
what's on the menu he's serving his cat
[Music]
Lionel Messi before Angel Di Maria
Lisandro Martinez a boss kuri can name
members of the Argentinian team faster
than what's on the menu of the
restaurant he works for
[Music]
the 46 year old comes from India's
Southern State of Kerala he says he's
never enjoyed being at work as much as
he does now
the World Cup is giving him a chance to
interact with customers like never
before
[Music]
Moroccan when African customers such as
Moroccans come we speak football when
people from the Gulf countries come we
speak about their players I'm crazy
about football I've been following the
game since the 1990 World Cup then I
watch Club matches foreign
[Music]
didn't play much football during his
childhood he says he developed a passion
as a teenager after watching a historic
match in 1990 when Cameroon defeated
defending Champions Argentina I'm not
believing about his knowledge this is a
it's a you know like a book if you want
any question about the football since 30
years 40 years he knows very well
the World Cup has brought more business
but 12 hour shifts leave kuri with
little time to catch the action live in
stadiums he's managed to watch just one
after a regular customer gave him a
ticket for a game
gets here it's time for a quiz I have
with me quiz Master Joseph John
I'll take it from here first team to
lift the World Cup after losing opening
nights hey who are the top goal scorer
of 2014 World Cup I miss rodicross
Colombian correct
which World Cup did Lionel Messi not for
a single goal 2010 who is the only male
player to score goals in five different
World Cups Cristiano Ronaldo Curry is a
quiz Master's delight and he hopes
someday he can take his encyclopedic
knowledge of the beautiful game Beyond
this restaurant